en este vídeo vamos a tratar de
encontrar a que es igual cuatro décimas
entre cinco pausa en el vídeo y piensen
en cómo lo resolverían por su cuenta de
hecho traten de resolver esto
visualmente vamos a resolverlo juntos
primero trataremos de pensar cómo se ven
cuatro décimas si pensamos en todo este
cuadrado como un entero vemos que está
dividido en diez columnas o secciones
iguales y que cuatro de esas décimas
están coloreadas aquí podemos ver que en
azul hay cuatro décimas como dividimos
esto entre cinco y que tenga sentido una
forma de pensar en esto es imaginar
cuatro décimas no como cuatro décimas
sino imaginar las como 40 centésimas
esto es imaginar las como 40 centésimas
podemos reescribir cuatro décimas entre
5 como 40 centésimas entre 5 y ahora
podemos pensar en tomar estas 40
centésimas
cada uno de estos cuadritos es una
centésima y dividirlas entre cinco
secciones iguales para luego ver cuántas
centésimas tiene cada una de estas
secciones vamos a hacerlo
esta es una estas son dos estas son tres
estas son cuatro y con esta tenemos
cinco secciones iguales cuantas
centésimas tiene cada una de estas
secciones iguales podemos ver que cada
una tiene una dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho por lo que cuarenta
centésimas divididas entre cinco va a
ser igual a ocho centésimas hay ocho
cuadritos en cada sección igual
escribimos ocho centésimas así 40
centésimas divididas entre 5 es igual a
8 centésimas y cuatro décimas divididas
entre 5 también es igual a 8 centésimas